today on stick to football we are gonna
preview and pick week six of the college
football season we're gonna talk a
little XFL because that draft is a
Bathgate going we're also gonna tell you
our guys for the 2020 NFL Draft I know a
lot of y'all been like hey we want more
draft coverage alright let's do it let's
hop into it I'm ready for it
we got Melo we got Connor boys mellows
rockin the quarters it because we are
gonna actually do week in Texas for
Texas oh you we can come too off the
cuff on Elm Street in Deep Ellum it will
not be a Nightmare on Elm Street
unless you're a Texas fan and it
probably will be doors open at 9:00
we'll be recording the podcast doing a
little pregame and then guys we're gonna
have a watch party there we're gonna end
up somewhere for LSU Florida I mean
usually that's the plan we will be
somewhere I don't know I will be out and
about who knows I'm just gonna go
wherever the spirit takes me but if you
start your day off the cuff you don't
have to worry about that
so that's the easiest way to do it and
we're excited to be there for the Red
River Rivalry tailgating in so many
names
it's the showdown it's the rivalry it's
I don't I wish we could still call it
the shootout I understand why we can't
but I wish we could we are gonna get
into the blind review as well but first
not a lot of news I did see right before
we sat down to record Thursday night
afternoon excuse me Zach Taylor says the
Cincinnati Bengals will not trade AJ
green and I know we didn't plan to talk
about this but I just want to say for a
team that's Owen five you have very few
assets you're not loaded with draft
capital AJ Green is thirty years old and
he is not going to help your football
team be good this year you're already
bad you're not making the playoffs
I understand holding on to maybe you're
only good player but this is a bad move
by the Bengals in my opinion trade him
to the Niners the Patriots trade him
somewhere and actually build some draft
out of course you want him to go to one
of those things that make sense I do
agree with you though in the sense that
what you're not building around AJ green
anymore that's not what's gonna happen
there with Cincinnati they have not
played well this season I don't want to
piss any bangels fans off but I think
they know that maybe it is time to move
on from AJ green let him go
to a contender like the Patriots like
the 49ers the packer somebody that needs
a receiver right now at least shop him
and see what you can get I'm with you
all the way I mean he's 31 he's been
hurt and he's a great player and when
he's on the field but every time he
comes back to the field he keeps getting
hurt see what you can get for him
my only thought here guys is that they
think hey maybe we're drafting a rookie
quarterback for next year and we want
him to have a franchise target when that
guy gets on the field yeah I really like
Tyler Boyd as well I should say ad
greenstone a good player I like Tyler
Boyd like Joe Mixon but we just haven't
seen a lot of production this year you
know out of those guys that Zach Taylor
struggles a little bit so the Bengals I
just see this is like good lord you're
like you're just admitting that you suck
away from tanking like that's the only
thing different between the Bengals the
Dolphins since the Dolphins tried to be
this bad in the Dolphins like you know
what yeah we are bad we're not
contending this year let's get rid of
some pieces and now like maybe minkum
Fitzpatrick
maybe you should have kept him without
picks gonna look pretty nice this would
be a nice bag that's a top seven pick
right now I think they're very very
happy I think if you wait towards the
deadline and you see what teams really
need you might get a team desperate like
the Packers or the 49ers that really
want to set their team over the top and
go after a marquee receiver like a.j
green I think a lot of teams are
probably worried about that injury and
how he's going to recover because he is
30 he's on the later end of his career
now so a lot of teams could be scared
off by that noted second-round pick drew
sample has two catches that was a great
pick guys great pick
I actually liked this move and this is a
team that we don't give a lot of credit
to but I would like to praise the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers for doing something this
week we knew that when they got Todd
Bowles they were gonna go after someone
like this they bring in familiar face
damn Buchanan to play that kind of
middle linebacker safety role but by
doing so they basically forfeited a
compensatory pick that they would have
received when Kwan Alexander went to the
San Francisco 49ers now it comes out I
think Adam Schefter was the first to
report it the Bucs are now in line to
get a third round compensatory pick in
the 2020 draft because they now lost
five free agents and only signed four
because Quan Alexander was a top
ade free-agent that's the word you get
into that third on it's confusing like
the formula my kidding me yeah it's a
lot of numbers to be on camera I wish we
had a like a I wish out a whiteboard I
could draw on but we don't but basically
because they signed one less free agent
than they lost and the guy they lost is
a high money player that's how you get a
third earn compact so by cutting a bad
player and Dale Buchanan the Bucks
basically won a third-round pick yeah
they've dug deep into the rule book and
how to get these compensatory picks so I
like the move by them cutting him you're
getting a third-round pick from a
linebacker that you're not getting any
production from so you're right we don't
talk about the Bucks at least not for
what they're doing well so this was a
good move by them to go and get some
draft capital back for a player that
you're really not even using and I think
when you look at Buchannon the impact or
lack thereof he's been playing special
teams for them it's not like he's been a
three down player for them where they're
losing a legitimate piece from this
defense with his loss yeah and I think
too like Melos like maybe they're
digging deep I also would throw up maybe
they didn't know they did Roberto well
in the second round maybe we need to hey
hey that's my guy maybe we need to be a
little more aware speaking of my guy so
that I really want to start doing and
we're you know four or five five weeks
into the college football season were
five weeks into the NFL Draft evaluation
season and I've seen a lot of tweets I
mean I think I saw an iTunes review
maybe where people are like god they're
not talking about the draft as much as
they used to and I want to say I do
apologize for that I love the draft it's
what I do
primarily for a living but you know we
are asked to do a lot of a lot of
different things now there's the
tailgate tour which takes up a lot of
our time we are covering NFL recovery
console ball we will never go away from
the draft but in October it's not always
a primary focus so we love y'all who are
here for the draft talk and I promise
it'll heat up it's gonna start heating
up this week because we are gonna debut
our first my guy segment of the year and
this is subject to change I'll speak for
all three of us when I say that happens
there guys sometimes I'll love him in
October and by January I'm like what was
I looking at what was I thinking so I
want to kick things off we're gonna do
a round one my guy and then a non round
one my guy cuz it'd be easy to be like
oh man
oh yeah right chase young so great yeah
we know yeah so these are maybe guys
even round one that you're a little
higher on them to consensus I'll start
it off with Joe borough he's my QB two
in this class I'm working on a new big
board right now he's gonna be in the top
20 for me I love what I have seen from
Joe borough that his his accuracy his
ability to make plays on the move I
think some of the touch passes he's made
and I know one of you is gonna jump in
and be like they haven't played anyone
well they're playing Florida this
weekend I think we'll get a pretty good
look at him after that one but no matter
who you play where he's putting the ball
is exceptional
throwing down the field more he's
attacking I do I think he has
prototypical size obviously the
leadership is off the charts good which
is someone I'll say about this
quarterback class other than what you
hear about Justin Herbert and Jacob
Eason we got a lot of really good
leaders in to uh and borough and Jalen
Hertz and Jake from so it's a very good
class for that but a 6-3 215 he's a
redshirt senior we're gonna see this guy
go to mobile and I'm saying it now he's
gonna have a daniel Jones like rise to
where her after mobile I wouldn't be
shocked if he's a top 10 pick that is
one advantage that he will have over a
lot of the other quarterbacks is that he
can go to the Senior Bowl he is not my
guy and I am definitely not as high on
him as you are very very anxiously
waiting that Florida game I think that's
gonna be a good showcase for him and the
receivers and the rest of that offense
I'm gonna go with the defensive side of
the football I'm going Isaiah Simmons
for mine I have loved this guy since I
started watching him last year mainly in
the national championship game I won't
pretend like I saw know who he was
coming out of high school but the way
that they used him at Clemson is so
impressed and I think that every
defensive coordinator in the NFL is
looking at this same holy [ __ ]
on first down we can play this guy at
linebacker it third and long we complain
nickel corner or safety and I think that
he has the athletic ability to
transition and play those roles in the
NFL he's a guy who's maybe gonna get
drafted as linebacker
some people might draft him as a safety
but he can play all over the field he
has the speed he has the range he's
about six for 230 and he can move I have
him comped right now to Derrick Johnson
that's more of the way that Derrick
Johnson played at Texas his speed side
lied to sign line he hasn't gotten into
the box and played much physically but
he can still run down he can make plays
and his ability to cover is better than
any linebacker I've ever seen and that's
why people are saying that he's a safety
he also looking at his stats this year
the dude has 43 tackles already in five
games and a lot of those I mean you're
playing at Clemson that first game at
Georgia Tech got out of hand pretty well
so I I really like him I'm gonna say
early on in the season he's my guy
I have him number five overall on my big
board right now one of the top defenders
he's a great player he's my guy so far
in honor this weekend I'm going with the
sooner and that CD lamb for me I just
think when you look at what he can do
before the catch word is route running
obviously he might not be the best at
separating but his ability at the catch
point I think you look at CD his ability
with the ball in his hands and what he's
done in this Oklahoma offense under
Lincoln Riley he's an explosive
playmaker in the class with a lot of
round one wide receivers who seem Jerry
Judy T Higgins the list goes on and on
I look at CD and I just think he could
really be a special special kind of
playmaker yeah and I think with CD he's
been overshadowed a little bit by
Charleston Rambo this year in terms of
catches at least but he has seven
touchdowns on 18 catches and I was
averaging almost 25 yards a catch yep
and some of that some of that is the
offense but there were times last year
where CD looked like the better overall
player the Marquis Brown and I've been
asked a lot not to piggyback off your
dude here Conor I've been asked why I
have him a wide receiver five and I'll
just be upfront with you I have two
concerns when it comes to CD lamb number
one speed because I do not see him beat
coverage a lot
I think he's wide the [ __ ] open a lot
which leads me to my number two
concerned is scheme I just want to see
him work himself open on his own this
weekend Texas is not great at corner but
they are at least gonna blanket him so I
think we'll get a chance to see him work
through some coverage a little bit and
see if he can get open on his own and I
think it's been fun to watch him this
year as Hollywood Brown has gone on to
the NFL to kind of be the featured guy
and you're seeing him draw that
attention while guys like Rambo are
getting better looks yeah and our guy
Cal Katara tied in
my round 2 to 7 guy and I actually Melo
sat down today and I said I can't
believe you didn't pick this dude he was
like no I don't like this guy well I'm
changing my pick then I'm taking Devin
Duvernay a slot receiver at Texas who's
really been asked to play on the outside
this was an area where they thought hey
they thought Bru McCoy would be the guy
well he got homesick they really thought
okay Colin Johnson's are number one he's
been a hurt again same story new year
with Colin Johnson so Devin Duvernay has
stepped up massively this year 45
catches
463 yards 40 DS the TDS are a little bit
low but I will say this because Texas
runs the ball a ton in the red zone with
Sam a lunker but Duvernay know he's not
even a number one receiver in the NFL
but I do think that he can be a very
good number three well I would draft him
in the second to third round range
depending what he runs now this is dude
that was running ten to hundreds in high
school so speed should not be an issue
he's 511 210 so he's kind of got that
stocky almost running back type build
but I think in the right scheme where
you were able to get him the ball
underneath or give him room to run I
don't think he's a stretch the field
kind of guy we also Sam Algar is a great
deep ball thrower sighs I think they're
holding each other back a little bit
there may be but I think Duvernay could
be very electric in the current NFL
where he's gonna get the ball in space
yeah and I'm gonna say this wearing the
Texas logo on my chest here I saw LJ
Humphrey do the same thing last year and
that's why I have concerns with Devin
Duvernay he's a great athlete works his
ass off in the locker room he's small
but I do have a lot of concerns there
he's getting the ball a lot on those
quick screens just like we saw with
Humphrey last year who went undrafted so
we will see what Devon do Rene can do my
guy who's not gonna probably not gonna
be drafted in the first round is Malik
Harrison the linebacker out of Ohio
State I am NOT an Ohio State fan I love
every one of their prospects coming out
this year even JK Dobbins I'm high on
him as well I really like what they have
going on there he's a big physical
linebacker
6-3 240 runs well and I think that he's
playing very well this seat this year
his senior year
now he's another guy that maybe we'll
see in mobile linebackers for some
reason you don't get a lot of the
linebacker talent there at the Senior
Bowl so hopefully he's a guy that we can
take a look at I love the way that he
gets off of blocks
I love his veteran leadership with this
linebacker group they've got like four
or five guys deep there and he's the
leader he's starting to be that alpha
dog I like the way he's playing so I'm
gonna say rounds 2 through 7 I really
like Malik Harrison yeah I'm going on
the defensive side of the ball as well
outside of round 1 for rounds 2 through
7 I'm going Jill Bochy I know we've
talked about him a lot on this show I
think when you look at Bochy tackling
machine great instincts great leader
plays on a really good defense where
that Sparty offense just can't do any
favors for them at any times but when
you look at Bochy there he's the dude in
the middle of the field now is he the
biggest line back in the world no but I
think he always beats everyone to the
spot so I love what Joe Bochy can do and
I think we've seen a transition over the
NFL the last couple years of linebackers
just getting smaller and really relying
on you know quickness first step and
just understanding and I think Bochy is
that kind of guy in the middle of the
defense we're a team we'll see him on
film and they'll go well he's a tackling
machine he's not the most physically
imposing kind of player but he's someone
that we can get in our room he could be
a leader right away and we could ask him
to do a lot of different things on maybe
all three downs and I think that's the
kind of player that a team will find a
steal maybe on day 2 of the draft for a
guy like Bochy yeah I like Bochy a lot
just the production it's good I feel
like there's a lot of linebackers like
that this year where they're just
they're productive they have all the
tools but like like Melo was saying even
we just don't see those guys get blown
up throughout the process unless they're
and I yeah a Simmons type go down so a
lot of line we've ever talked another
guy just like Devin Weaver is so
productive David Woodward another like
they're just a lot of productive
linebackers right it's blind review time
let's go we got one right last week I
just want to congratulate talked about
that we haven't but we like nailed it
last week that it was pretty amazing we
have the New York Giants visiting the
New England Patriots this week and guys
it was a much better game than I thought
I thought the Patriots were gonna
absolutely kill the Giants they almost
did but not quite they were favored by
17 points the fact that the Patriots
come out win this game by 23 points
looked very good moving the football
just didn't have anything to stop this
crew of running back so they're running
the ball they're catching the ball
they're blocking well great win here for
the Patriots the cool crisp Foxborough
wind blowing for the Patriots as they
pick up a win at home I think the
biggest takeaway here is that the
Patriots aren't going to trip up like
that we're not gonna see a Chiefs Colts
game where even if they're a little bit
banged up it's just not gonna matter man
I feel bad for Daniel Jones today and
he's gonna be in the tub because that
best defense in the NFL got him again
the Patriots streak holds no touchdown
passes surrendered this year and once
again they're allowing seven points a
game on the season we saw it again
they're holding right where they're
supposed to be the Giants got to start
thinking about 2020 and they gotta start
thing about drafting some wide receivers
for Daniel Jones
yeah I'm a happy better over here cuz I
put a little money on this game when I
got the opening line at 16 and a half
and for the Giants I mean Daniel Jones
didn't have anyone obviously no say Quan
no sterling Shepherd no have an Ingram
what can you expect against a great
defense on the road at New England and
just to see them lose by 23 guys we got
to start talking about this offensive
line I think it had a really good start
of the year but now you're seeing some
protection issues on the left side for
the young quarterback they really need
to find a way to get the ball out
quicker especially when Ingram and say
Quan are back but New England they are
just steamrolling right now and this New
England defense looks as good as I can
ever remember them being it's not Tom
Brady carrying the team anymore it's hey
we could play any style of football
because we know our defense is gonna
shut out the opposition it is week six
it's time to preview and pick some games
let's go around the horn I'm 23 and 12
Melo 23 and 12 Connor is 16 and 9
because he missed week one we've fallen
into a trap a lot of us are picking the
same games I'm going to encourage us to
shake things up a little bit this week I
say that after we've already picked the
game yeah baby doesn't like doesn't look
good maybe someone will just get crazy
and go off the top here game number one
is the one we will be at number six
Oklahoma favored by ten and a half
neutral site game against the Texas
Longhorns the over/under is seventy five
and a half I would say crush that over
because Texas can't tackle and I don't
think bringing it Chris
in as a whatever - unpaid defensive
assistant this week is get these change
anything I will say this when it comes
to the Red River shootout showdown
excuse me you have to almost like take
everything off the plate like right like
records don't really matter because
there's so much emotion and energy
surrounding this game Texas won last
year really within the last second field
goal so you have to almost overlook what
teams have been doing and neither team
has really play to anyone Texas played
LSU and lost so even look at it Oklahoma
like it's hard to be that excited about
oh you don't play anyone that said I
fully expect Oklahoma to beat the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of my Texas
Longhorns I would take Oklahoma I would
take points
I think they win by more than ten in
each of Texas is defense is arguably the
worst in college football
whoa-ohh Houma has Jalen hurts Vinny
lamb Rambo Cal Katara Trey sermon
they're going to score 56 points
Oklahoma we'll see I think that this
game I'm gonna pick Oklahoma to win - I
actually think it's gonna be close
because traditionally it's only it has
been in the last couple years it has
been since I mean 2013 2012 was the last
time that this game really got out of
hand
so I do think that Sam Bellinger in this
offense can score points on Oklahoma the
bad news for all of us Texas fans
there's no way in hell you're stopping
this Oklahoma offense like Texas can't
do it I don't know that there are many
defenses that can they just look too
good Jalen hurts playing this whole
season pissed off and Nick Saban is just
ruining the big 12 he's gonna run right
through these guys it's gonna be a
high-scoring game it's gonna be fun to
watch
even if Texas loses like I think they
will yeah I think Texas will keep this
game really closed for at least the
first half maybe three quarters but I'm
picking Oklahoma guys and I'm picking
Oklahoma to maybe even cover that line I
think when you look at it their offense
hasn't even really been human yet they
don't even look vulnerable to anything
they haven't shown any signs of weakness
and I think something that we you have
pointed out time and time again with
Texas's can this Texas secondary cover
not just see
um Rambo Kalka Terra can they cover
anyone in this game who like which guy
do you take away from Oklahoma it
doesn't matter because someone else is
gonna be open and if no one's open jalen
hurd is a good runner with a good
offensive line
I just think unfortunately I hope it's a
great game I just think Texas is a
little out match on one significant side
of the ball two things I will say Kansas
did slow down Oklahoma a little bit last
week before the second half when
Oklahoma really put the foot down on the
guy that's a blue print out there
exactly and I'll say this this will be
my fourth Red River game that I've been
to Texas has never won a Red River game
that I've been at so I'm a jinx
I apologize Texas is gonna lose let's
move on Michigan State at number eight
Wisconsin Wisconsin favored by ten and a
half the over under a scorching 40
points the Badgers just run all over
Michigan State I know we've talked about
Michigan State's defense you know of
Michigan State's defense like they've
got you know some talented dudes in
there but they can't really stop anyone
and there's no one in the wild right
there's no way I see them stopping
Jonathan Taylor no way no one else has
if Jonathan Taylor is healthy he's gonna
go off for 200 225 yards to score three
touchdowns and that's just how they beat
you
Michigan State's offense is just
absolutely atrocious so even if you can
start to slow down Taylor I don't think
they can score enough to win this game
see I think that they can stop Taylor
the bad news for all the Spartan fans so
when you stop Jonathan Taylor who still
runs for 120 yards and one touchdown and
that's probably just not gonna do it so
I'm gonna pick Wisconsin as well but I'm
gonna take the under I think this is a
low-scoring game I think both teams are
gonna come out try to control the ball
not get any not doing anything too crazy
with it so I'm gonna take the under here
I think it hits under 40 and I'm gonna
take Wisconsin win I do think Jonathan
Taylor's gonna have a good game but
they're gonna force Jack cone to throw
the ball
they are probably sick of watching
Jonathan Taylor run all over the Big Ten
so they're gonna load the box and say
all right we are making this quarterback
beat us we might put nine guys in there
with two corners on the hand but we are
going to make this quarterback beat us
so I I expect a slow start here for
Jonathan Taylor but I do think Wisconsin
wins yeah this might be a 10
six kind of football game where it's
just a punt fest it's a turnover fest
and nobody's moving the ball everyone's
just trying to win the game of field
position and man what do we say about
college kickers they're not you know
ones to rely on here but when it comes
down to it for me it's Badgers all the
way all right here we go a game of two
top 20 teams number 10 Penn State -
three and a half playing in the pink
locker rooms at Iowa the over-unders 40
- I would take the under on this one and
I'm gonna surprise everyone I'm gonna
take the dogs in this I like the
Hawkeye's to win outright and it's not a
popular pick even like I looking at the
the picks that you know ESP and everyone
else is made everyone's on the Nittany
Lions basically in this one I believe
that Nate Stanley can get it done
against this Penn State secondary I
think we also see the run game of Iowa
be productive this week here's the thing
though you have to stop KJ hammer and no
one's really done that so far this year
so we're gonna need to see Sean Clifford
contained but I think I was just so
disciplined it's such a hard place to
play not just because the pink locker
rooms this is a great fan base it's a
night game so I and it's gonna be cold
up here there's like a cold front
hitting the Midwest it's gonna be cold
it's probably gonna be rainy I think
that favors Iowa when they're at home
yeah and I'm gonna go with Penn State
here I like this defense and you watched
Iowa play last week
Michigan's shut them down ten to three
was the score on that one so I agree
with you I think KJ Hamlet gonna go off
because I don't know that Iowa can stop
him I don't know if anybody really can
stop him and I was very hard on Sean
Clifford I was wrong I'm sorry - Sean
Clifford it looks like he can actually
play some quarterback running back by
committee he's still gonna get it done
for Penn State Michael Parsons and this
defense pretty damn special though
they're only allowing seven points a
game I know that they've got some
cupcakes on that schedule so far but I
like this defense and I think they can
get after Nate Stanley with guys like
gross Matos he's gonna be able to get a
good test in against these good tackles
so I'm gonna go Penn State I'm gonna go
low score and I don't think it's gonna
get out of hand here but Penn State wins
yeah a pretty simple equation for me in
this one the Nittany Lions play good
defense Iowa can't really score so when
it comes down to it for me Penn State
wins on the heels of their rushing
attack where once again I
think this could be a 14-10 14-6 kind of
football game
I would definitely steer clear and go on
the under of that line of 42 but I think
Penn State wins
we got a rivalry game USC at number nine
Notre Dame Notre Dame's favored by 11
you're over unders 57 and a half I don't
know who USC is still and I think I said
that every week but everything I just I
don't know who they are man they've just
been so inconsistent
last week they can only score 14 points
against Washington way before that they
scored 30 against Utah like I truly
don't know this is the most bipolar team
in all of college football they have
played well they they beat Stanford
earlier again the Utah win but after
watching Washington just dismantled them
I don't have a lot of faith in USC and
I'm not a Notre Dame guy and I'll say
this Notre Dame lost to Georgia they
have not played anyone else this year I
think Virginia is in a normal year
Virginia should not be in the top 25
they beat Bowling Green last week by 52
congratulations I still feel like Notre
Dame is a little bit overrated but they
always are right I don't think US team
to it to expose that so I'm gonna pick
Notre Dame but I hate this game now this
game does make me nervous with USC
because if this offense is hitting it's
hard to stop it's just can you get after
the quarterback which I think Notre Dame
will do with they're good edge rusher so
I'm gonna take Notre Dame that
point-spread makes me nervous though I
probably wouldn't put anything on it now
I'm at 11 I'll take the over I think
both offenses can score the football but
I'm not gonna take the point spread
I think this rivalry game is probably
always gonna play a little bit closer
than you think
even when USC is having I wouldn't say
it down here but they're kind of
expecting a coaching change by the end
of the year I think this game stays
close but it is gonna be high-scoring
yeah like Matt kind of said this USC
team is all over the place it's gonna be
a chilly chilly Saturday in South Bend
for USC to go to Notre Dame
I just think Notre Dame is gonna come
out ready to play and I think they're
gonna easily handle this USC team seeing
that USC team against that Washington
secondary they really could not get much
going at all and throughout the entire
game until the end and I think it's
gonna be a very very similar performance
against for them against the Irish
Michael Pittman has to have a game like
yet against Utah to win that ballgame
like that's it and
he needs to step up I think it generally
said that one really good game all right
the game of the week and this is
absolutely the game of the week number
seven Florida at number five LSU LSU is
favored by 13 and a half boys looking
over 55 and listen to this stat from the
bear no not our producer whiskey Dan the
bear at ESPN dating back to 2010 the
last 12 ranked teams to pull a home
upset so that's Florida last week
beating Auburn and face another ranked
team as an underdog so that's them this
week against LSU they're 1 and 11
straight up Wow or an 8 against the
spread the only team to do it
Ole Miss beat a.m. and then upset
Alabama in 2014 so basically Florida's
not gonna win this ballgame it's almost
statistically impossible coming off the
weak they just had and I really don't
think they can anyway we talked about
Joe burrow earlier he's just crew of
receivers I think Justin Jefferson goes
off this week and also I would I believe
that Grant Delpit we saw him bounce back
last week with a pick I think he's
playing much better as we get closer
Jacob Phillips at linebacker I think
they can really frustrate Kyle Trask
they could shut down the floor to run
game which is the key for them right now
when they beating Auburn is from let's
like from P Ryan guys like that being
able to control the clock we don't
control the line of scrimmage
keep pressure off the young quarterback
they were able to do it I guess
Auburn they deserve a lot of credit
because Derek Brown is that [ __ ] beast
but I don't think they could do it again
Stella here's the problem with this game
Matt you look at it and it's a seven
verse five matchup and there's a
thirteen and a half point line that's
because nobody goes into Baton Rouge at
night and wins the Gators will be lucky
to come out of this game alive I have
seen the fan base there at 10:30 I'm
looking clarified to walk into that
Stadium at 7 p.m. on a night game I
would be terrified to leave that Stadium
it's not good news for the Florida fans
I'm sorry I like your program I like
your team a little bit I even kind of
like Kyle Trask but Baton Rouge on a
Saturday night No thank you unless you
are wearing yellow and purple at Florida
has been proving me wrong since week
zero let's see it's not cutting time
over here there we go
this is the one if you're gonna really
prove me wrong go to LSU [ __ ] the
thirteen and a half
and win the damn game I don't think they
will I don't think it'll be a good game
I think the Tigers are gonna absolutely
roll in this one
how many uh your Genet onyx now right
yeah 2019 genes gene tees GT so we're
gonna have caught so much Hendrix it's
gonna be flowing through Connors little
veins by seven o'clock when this game
kicks off the Instagram live content is
gonna be amazing we hosted by Matt
emails right Maddie Mills from the back
of a golf cart I'm a little upset we
didn't go to that game instead cuz I
loved Baton Rouge we'll get back there
maybe next year mellow you got your game
of the week double super underdog
locksmith game of the week to bet your
money on because I don't have the nuts
to bet my own money on Matt that's what
the people call it and I'll tell you
what folks it hit last week and we
didn't talk about it enough when UCF
went down to Cincinnati this week I'm
going back to the well with Syracuse I
really liked this team early on in the
season and somehow they are a three and
a half point dog against North Carolina
State put your money on this one I think
that Syracuse can get the job done that
defense is too good
they have enough offense to beat North
Carolina State put your money on them
that's the locksmith game of the week if
you haven't heard the XFL is coming back
and I'm actually excited because it
sounds like it'll be a little bit of
like a throwback to that 80's 90's
football that we all miss the new year
Chris Berman doing the highlights of
this thing so we thought this week let's
look at the XFL draft pool why not
because there's not that much going on
and I'm excited I really am to get I was
a believer in the AAF until you realize
that ownership actually didn't know what
they were doing so now we get the XFL
and I don't know if ownership here is
what they're doing but it's gonna be
exciting for a couple weeks yeah I mean
they at least have some people running
this thing it seems like it's a little
bit more credible than what we had with
the last one that track so I'd like to
XFL to I'm excited for more football
anytime it's on my screen I think it's a
good idea I mean this is gonna be I
actually am excited after seeing the
draft pools like they released the first
one and I was like uh-oh I was like I
think I know like five people on that
list right they released one every day
so it's it's gotten a lot better I will
gladly kick things off
you gotta cool soul anyway so we're
doing our top five players in the XFL I
almost really did my top five favorite
stories I don't think these would be the
five best players in the axe FL oh god
no the first one boy is this one fun
Taku Lee he is on the Japanese
international team and he is a running
back he has played for the unicorns at
one time he I mean he came over here
from Japan
watches highlights right now in YouTube
it's a lot of fun we have a Japanese
running back I am rooting for this guy
I'm excited for this guy and I mean the
film is fun I don't know what it'll look
like when he's over here playing in the
XFL against some decent football players
but at the end of the day Taku Lee is
somebody that we can all root for as we
see more international players not just
in the NFL program but now clearly in
the XFL program next Vinnie pop Olli
yeah you recognize that name you ever
seen vincible this is the son of Vince
Papale E then he played a lot of special
teams and a little bit of receiver at
Delaware for a couple years good athlete
tough guy he's getting a chance at the
XFL let's see invincible to a couple of
years from now the XFL version number
three I actually think this guy is a
talented player
Devante Kincade a very good player at
Grambling a really good player at
Grambling really a good running
quarterback I don't know if the NFL just
didn't think if he had the arm for that
you know to get a tryout at the NFL
level but I think Kincaid will be one of
those fun players in the XFL because of
his playmaking ability and I think a lot
of people especially fans of the
Grambling program are gonna be excited
to see him play again number two this is
Matt's favorite player Trent Richardson
Trent Richardson will now be playing in
his fourth league I believe from NFL CFL
AAF XFL I mean we're always going to
turn the TV on when Trent Richardson not
is on whether he's good or not number
one this name blew my mind when I saw it
on there Darren habis the Oregon
quarterback the guy before Marcus
Mariota this story was unbelievable he
was a fun player at Oregon he left early
the NFL did just never worked out he's
29 years
old already but I remember how explosive
those Ducks offenses were what Thomas as
a runner as a thrower I haven't seen
this guy and so long was wondering what
happened to him and he's been playing in
some it looks like semi-pro kind of
leagues and now we get to see him get
his shot in the XFL so for me I don't
think these guys are the five best
talented players in the league but I
think they're all players we can
individually root for in some kind of
way yeah I actually had to look at like
some of your guys I saw Darren Thomas on
your list but I didn't recognize who
that actually was and then Trent
Richardson they somehow slid that name
in on me I did I didn't see him get it I
didn't here's my theory that
[ __ ] burned me once I'm not
doing it again
we should have made you do it next year
number five for me
Roberto Aguayo I liked him and I was
reading for the kicker that got drafted
so high he was not that terrible in the
NFL so he was he converted 71% of his
field goals at least I mean the Bears
have had worse kickers so I want to see
him get a second chance I think the NFL
is so terrified to put their name on him
or give him a chance that I want to see
what he can do in the XFL and I think
for a kicker I mean if he just comes out
and can be consistent he'll get himself
a try out there so I am gonna go with
the kicker I don't even care I'm not
scared next up for me number four I'm
gonna go with quarterback Taylor
Cornelius out of Oklahoma State I liked
him he was only a 1 year starter really
didn't get a whole lot of time to play
but I like his his potential as a big
guy with a big arm we'll see what he can
do I think before too long he's probably
gonna be in some coaching circuits next
number 3 Katie cannon out of Baylor
second-round draft picks super athlete I
think that his speed at the XFL is going
to be exciting I'm not sure how they're
doing the coin toss or what they're
doing at the 50 yard line for the XFL
this go-around but his speed is gonna be
valuable on that except they'll field as
well as Ryan Broyles former receiver
from Oklahoma this guy used to tear it
up into big 12 and he had his chance in
the NFL
I mean his junior year he caught 131
passes at Oklahoma I think he's gonna be
a very talented receiver that people are
gonna have a hard time sticking with at
the XFL level in
number one for me Tony Dungy son that's
a joke if you don't know it Eric Dungey
the Syracuse quarterback that everybody
loved last year we had a lot of people
asking about him you see a draft
prospect what can he do
very athletic I want to see if his arm
has developed what he's been doing for
this last year but I know that he'll be
able to take the ball and run it the
offenses I don't really know what they
look like right now are they gonna be
more college with the spread where
you're moving your quarterback around or
is it gonna be NFL based where you want
that pocket passer or what we're gonna
see but I think that Eric Dungy can
perform in this league and will be a
valuable player Tony Dungy son when I
saw it on your list was like okay now I
get it now now I know why he's on there
right number five for me Trey McBride a
player who actually really liked as a
draft prospect coming out in the 2015
draft the Titans picked him up in the
seventh round he was a good player at
William and Mary bastard on the NFL for
a couple years but 6-foot 245 pounds so
he I makes you see is he gonna be more
of like a Flex tight end like where is
he gonna get used in the in the XFL
because excuse me
6-foot 210 pounds I'm excited to see
where they use him so I really did
thought that like this dude had some
potential he ran a four three seven back
in the day so I like his ability a lot
it get him in the slot get him as a
return man so Trey McBride could be one
of those big play guys in the XFL that
maybe doesn't jump to the league but can
at least shine for this for this level
football number four Connor cook so I
was never high on kind of a high on
Connor cook as some of my peers but I
did like at least his talent coming out
in the 2016 NFL Draft the Raiders
drafted him in the fourth round he got a
little bit of a chance to play when
tarik car got hurt but it just wasn't
meant to be he bounced around last year
this year he was actually with the
Detroit Lions the XFL is kind of trying
to make him a thing like he is their
name that they're marketing so I was
yeah great I will say this
Connor cooks family was not great to me
in his pre-draft process so you're right
bet then I will be following this dudes
every throw at this level to see how he
could do so this is not a redemption
story I am watching out
just petty it's a revenge I just wanted
to write Dead Redemption exactly that's
all this is number three and I will say
the rest of minor guys I actually like
David Cobb when he was at Minnesota I
really liked him as a running back
prospect he was physical I really
thought that there would be a chance he
could carve out a nice little NFL career
it just did not happen fifth round draft
pick by the Titans I thought he was that
you know physical running back who's
gonna be a great match to you know kind
of a thunder and lightning system there
it never happened he's only 26 years old
so there's still a lot of tread left on
those tires I'll be excited to see where
he lands number two just to show I'm not
a homer an Oklahoma player one of my
favorite college football players of all
time a fullback Dmitri flowers ivory
truly believe this that we can see the
XFL help be a feeder League in a lot of
ways because the NFL we've already seen
guys like juice in San Francisco we're
starting to see Alec Engel we're seeing
more fullback usage in the NFL I think
Dmitri flowers just needs to chants to
remind people what he was like in
college because he's a good receiver out
of the backfield he can run the ball a
little bit and I think he's a very good
move blocker so I'm excited to see
Dmitri flowers then my top guy gotta go
quarterback gotta go
very small school Joe Callahan who
actually looked pretty good in the
preseason so Joe Callahan out of Wesley
yep that is in Delaware I thought he
looked good over the last couple pre
seasons where we got a chance to watch
him play he was with the Packers for a
little bit here's what the Bucks and the
Ravens this past offseason I like Joe
Callahan he's the little dude he's like
61 200 pounds he runs around and makes a
ton of plays I didn't use a decent
quarterback better than Connor Cook
let's be honest so I wouldn't be
surprised
Joe Callahan might be your XFL MVP
season one it is draft on draft time I'm
ready to crack open some beers so we're
gonna go do that as soon as we're done
with this Andrew Magnussen who better be
in Dallas this weekend or I will revoke
his stick to football hall of fame
membership I'm not joking well in honor
of this week's rivalry games what's your
favorite moment from the Texas oh you
rivalry bonus points for discussing
favorite moment
moments in other rivalries LSU Florida
FSU Clemson Notre Dame USC etc so
obviously we sit here as Texas fans you
and I Matt so my favorite memory from
the Texas o u game was Jamaal Charles
run the year that they won the national
championship that dude just took off you
know it might have not even been that
year but you just took off right up the
middle it really set the game over the
top and Texas ran away with it it was
not even close so that's my favorite one
but I know that the Oklahoma fans like
Mason Whitlock will tell me when Roy
Williams when Chris and mine and hit
Chris Simms that was one of the best
plays I've ever seen in college football
it happened to this rivalry game so I
did love that one
even though I had to watch it from the
other point of view I think for me like
Ricky Williams and is probably the big
one or you'd like night it would've been
97 like for Ricky Williams to just go
off against Oklahoma
that's probably was like my introduction
to the rivalry in a lot of ways
unfortunately the Roy waivers play is
the best play in the history of this
rivalry I think last year watching Ellen
Gore just take over games with his legs
last year was one of my favorite moments
because it just it felt like Oklahoma
could not stop him on the other side of
it I was in the Cotton Bowl watching
Baker Mayfield do the horns down to the
Texas student section like I don't
really like Oklahoma obviously but like
to have to win a game and then have the
balls to do that like that's one of
those I didn't like it but I'm never
gonna forget at moments so I will say
that game has not produced like a lot of
iconic moments though not like some of
the others have yeah it hasn't been like
real close I know that we talked about
earlier but it's never like coming down
to the last second Drive or anything
like that and last year did but it just
felt anti-climatic I don't know for me
and this is something that I'd tweeted
out I just love all the LSU special
teams fakes against Florida there's like
900 of them and it's just kickers and
punters running for huge first downs for
touchdowns and even on the botched one
where they flip it over their head and
it bounces and he still picks it up and
runs it's unbelievable how many times
that can happen to the same team
and it is something that everyone's I
hope Florida does it to LSU this time
around so everybody's like oh [ __ ] now
we have to go Scout their special teams
we have a fast punter I think yeah
greatest rivalry play I've ever seen
though is the Chris Davis hundred nine
yard return in the Iron Bowl like yes I
grew I mean it was a walk-off return
like that's it like it doesn't get any
bigger than that oh yeah I mean I went
nuts and I didn't really have a routine
and did not care who won I was amazing
that he kept running the football yeah I
think when you look at the other games
like Florida State and Clemson I don't
even know if that's really a rivalry I
think both teams have been pretty
dominant during their time so it's not
like we're seeing the best of Florida
State against the best of Clemson but
there was a game I think it was maybe
Jameis is last year there at Florida
State when Clemson was coming off the
bus and they're rocking the bus it was a
night game I think that's when we saw
the switch from ok Florida State's
running the ACC yeah - now Clemson is
you look at Notre Dame USC the bush push
had to be the best highlight from that
game that I can remember I know that
there's probably like some game from the
70s or 80s where people like yeah you
have to mention that one well I didn't
see that one but I did see Reggie Bush
push Matt Leinart into the end zone to
keep that season alive all right next
question this is from DG i-20 - I like
this question should quarterback Jordan
love enter the transfer portal as a grad
transfer after the season and go to a
power five school I think first and
foremost I actually don't know if Jordan
Love is on track to graduate I would
assume so as a fourth-year junior but
you never know so I think that's the
first thing I don't want to speculate
too far since we don't know if he will
be able if he'll be graduating or not
now secondly no I think if you are on
the radar as a first round quarterback I
know a lot of people our good friend Jim
naggy and I have had a lot of
conversations about Jordan love as well
that there's a growing belief in NFL
circles that this dude would be a top 15
pick you don't need to go prove yourself
at a power five school because the NFL
already likes you
yeah let's talk about Josh Allen at
Wyoming - there's always receivers
suckers oh line suck should he transfer
nah because scouts know that he has
nothing around him and I think we're
Jordan love you watch the LSU game
you see moments then that's we can
people excited worse like ah he's
overcoming the lack town around him with
his playmaking ability with his arm with
his vision with how he can improvise you
just know that his numbers are not gonna
be what get him drafted yeah and I think
you're right when you say he's already
on the radar it wasn't like Tyree
Jackson last year I think that he could
have maybe benefitted from going to a
different power five school a lot of
people are already watching Jordan love
they're familiar with what he can do so
I don't know that going and competing
against somebody else is gonna do it I
mean we just watched him play LSU I mean
he's competing against some good schools
even though he is out there playing for
Utah State yeah if you're expected to go
in the first two to three rounds they
usually are gonna go especially at
quarterback where you're gonna be given
some time to develop or you're gonna be
given a chance eventually to start and I
think for love I'm not there as a
believer right now but I think and this
is something that matt has preached a
lot on the midweek show is the NFL
values his traits right now and if he
continues to show off those traits he
won't have to go to another school play
another year college football because
guess what the traits are already on the
film yeah it's easy sometimes right like
we're joint love you know what you're
looking for and you're just looking for
the the traits it's just like scouting
Josh Allen all over again different
players not comparing them but alright
kg Whittington sounds like a coat
company or something he says I mocked
jobber Oh to go to the Titans if they go
eight and eight and end up with a mid
round pick do you think Burrell will
follow that more will they have to move
up to get him I think it's too early to
say right now we're good people go mock
drafts like we're in the process of
ranking people right now and even that
floats and it's flexible so a mock draft
right now it isn't exercised mostly in
team needs and player value so I could
see Burrell right now being a mid round
one value but quarterbacks always float
yes what happened and if he's
quarterback to there's no way that an
eight and eight team could pick him up
not if if he is QB to the Bengals are
gonna pick him up or the Dolphins will
pick him up there are a lot of teams
that need a quarterback that are gonna
be picking very early in the draft yeah
I think it's all over the place right
now with jobber oh this has been a
astronomical kind of rise right now I
mean before the year I feel like we had
Joe
burro in the third to fifth round and
now it seems like every week we're
talking about him being in the first
round and this feels like the
conversation is moving will he be in the
top ten
I'm not saying he won't be I'm just
saying it is definitely a very
wait-and-see approach right now I just
think with the way quarterbacks are
reached upon on top of the fact Justin
Herbert has not really done much for
anyone this year honestly this is a
chance for Herbert for borough to really
continue to climb I mean right now the
drafted Cincinnati Washington Miami the
Jets Miami again quarterback it's - it
goes first well I did borrow goes third
or fifth like that's just how it goes
dolphins have to get it well I mean
unless Josh Rosen you know he's got an
audition here we'll see what happens but
there's just a lot of what-if scenarios
right now pod Punxsy Calif I don't know
guys yeah and it keeps him on there why
do you think Chuba Hubbard isn't getting
more Heisman love or talk to Bell at all
as a draft prospect hey let me suppose
he's gonna talk about the draft prospect
if you listen to this show three times a
week
we love Chuba Hubbard go ahead sorry his
team has two losses that's why he's not
getting talked about as a Heisman I you
can't have two losses this early in the
season they're three and two right now
and be considered for a Heisman that's
why when we talk about guys that are
we're talking about maybe Jonathan
Taylor at running back he's been going
off and his team is still undefeated
we're talking about - oh we're talking
about Joe borough jaylen Hertz what do
all those guys have in common they
haven't lost a game yeah so I think
that's why we're talking about these
Heisman guys you look at that first it's
kind of a team award - you have to be on
a very successful team and you have to
put up the numbers he's doing it I mean
even last game 156 yards three
touchdowns
I love Trueba Hubbard another reason why
people maybe aren't talking about him
that much he's a redshirt sophomore a
lot of things I probably didn't expect
this production out of him and they
probably expected okay let's look at
this guy next year because he had a
great freshman season last year so he
probably just wasn't really on the radar
as a draft prospect coming into the
season at least he wasn't for me he's a
guy I thought would go back to school
and be a three year player but I think
maybe we will have to put him on the
board like Matt said we like him he's
definitely talked about here on stick to
foot
all you can get it done out of the
backfield and run to the ball very good
player
just probably not gonna be a Heisman
candidate I just think when you come
into the season you have names like
DeAndre swift jonathan taylor travis ETN
I mean this list really goes like even
Keyshawn Vaughn those were the guys we
were talking about all summer
now Hubbard comes in lights the world on
fire he's been phenomenal I think we've
been big fans of him as a college
football player but like Melo said
redshirt sophomore you're like oh damn
he is eligible if he wants to leave and
as we often say on this show if you're a
running back and the draft stock is hot
and you can get out of town
get out of town so maybe that decision
will come earlier than expected for a
guy like Hubbard no [ __ ] way I would
go back to school no never
running back no way no water nope not
gonna happen sucks let's see this name
Gianluca martini I think you guys are
punking me with your names lately
goodness gracious who would you rather
have for now in the future Nick and Joey
Bosa or JJ and TJ watt I also Celeste
okay supposes BOCES if I'm doing it for
right now I would take the Watts I think
that they're probably both healthy right
now but it's hard to do that in the same
week where we saw Nick Bosa almost
single-handedly beat the Cleveland
Browns and then Joey Bosa if he's ever
healthy fully they're gonna be very hard
to stop so if you're building a future
around him it's got to be the BOCES but
I do love TJ why he's one of my favorite
players to watch dude is constantly just
killing the backfield he's there he's
getting fumbles pressures on the
quarterback a little bit of sax to I
mean you can't go wrong but the BOCES
are probably the easy answer yeah I
really like both I mean or all four
excuse me both both that's the brothers
I would take the BOCES as well
Nick Bosa you could make an argument is
the best pass rusher in the NFL so far
this season definitely on on numbers on
pressures on impact snaps he actually is
the best pro Football Focus has him
ranked as the best he had seven
pressures against the Steelers he owned
the Cleveland Browns on on Monday night
that's not just me being a homer
but Bosa has been he's been absolutely
unstoppable now we'll see if that can
keep up last question from our guy the
dildoes er who hung out with us in
Wisconsin yeah I
a name like that is just set up for me
to mess up I love it basically like
that's a real name yep alright with the
college season coming to the halfway
point who are some prospects who've made
huge jumps up your big boards as all of
some guys who have taken big falls down
your rank I like that I mentioned
earlier like I'm in the process mellow
and I were talking about it before the
show today of ranking I'm about almost
200 players ranked so I think some the
biggest jump for me if you guys know
someone on top your head go for it I got
a lot I have somewhere else falling yeah
there you go I'll stay with LSU I'm not
pleased with what I've seen so far out
of Grand dumpin I really thought that he
was gonna have a big year bigger than
what he has so far and it is Thursday so
maybe comes Saturday against Florida
that could really change but so far I
have moved him down my board the
coverage skills I know he had an
interception but it still it doesn't
look like he's that elite level
centerfielder do it all safety that we
kind of thought he was looks like he
might be more of like that strong safety
type guy so we'll see what he can do
from Saturday against Florida but for
right now I have dropped him down my
board hey we were really nice to LSU
during the pay segment I guess it's time
to be a little mean here I'm gonna go
right back to that Tiger as well I
haven't seen anything out of Kayla
Vaughn chase on this year no I wouldn't
know he's playing football and I know a
lot of people including us on potential
we didn't write it in pen we were like
you know chase on I'll be back this year
maybe he could be a top 15 pick because
he's a pass rusher with high end traits
I just I haven't seen anything to get me
excited right now I think another one I
don't think it's his fault but I think I
was expecting maybe too much Isla
viscous you know I just don't think he's
in the right opportunity to be a seedy
Lam a jerry judy at E Hagins he's not
getting those kind of opportunities
right now a Colorado where the
manufactured touches look phenomenal but
at the end of the day I think I was
hoping he was the top 15 player and I'd
be really surprised if he's drafted as
one I mean the biggest jump for me is
Jalen Hertz and there's no question
about it because I I thought day three
when we last saw him at Alabama know all
my scouting friend
running back they really thought he
would move to running back nick saban
even thought that so yes I should have
known you're right but that is the
biggest jump for me I think the biggest
fall I was gonna say Kay LaVon Chaisson
he's really been disappointing this year
goodness gracious
jakey Dobbins this is a huge jump for me
as well I'm down on the the Vandy guys I
really thought that we would see better
play from Vaughn from Pinckney and from
the other receiver name just escaped me
starts with an L yeah I know this is
great possum Lipscomb yeah that's coming
up so I've just really not liked what
I've seen from that Vandy trio and I
know the quarterback play has not been
good but I expected them to overcome it
a little bit so but I would say Dobbins
is Dobbins and hurts and my two biggest
risers but I don't you know I don't have
really anybody that's jumped up the
board for me I am I've been very
impressed with tua this year I and I had
a lot of questions but I am coming into
it so having him play the way that he
has but I feel like I've talked about
that enough already
other than that I mean my top five guys
right now I have chase young Jerry Judy
to a Jeff a CUDA I've come around on him
but I was never blow on him I always
knew that he was gonna be great I mean I
saw this guy play as a freshman I was
like that's the best corner on Ohio
State so always been high on him Isaiah
Simmons and then I have number six a JEP
Anessa so I have an hour in high-top
sixes are identical that's well twinsies
right
here's another player I absolutely love
and again my big board is is being
updated currently I absolutely love
Derek brown Auburn like Derek Brown is
number 10 for me right now so my top
five chase young Jerry Judy to a Okuda
Simmons epinet just like mellow
I stopped T Higgins at 7:00 grant Delpit
at 8:00 Andrew Thomas at 9:00 Derek
Brenton I mean brown brown is like and I
even saw it's funny before we did the
show I saw Daniel Jeremiah tweet about
it and I agree
Branson easy eval it's just how much you
when you're an interior defensive
lineman like I guess I you came to say
because Quinton Williams just went three
I don't think Derek Browns going in the
top five no easily an easy evals the top
15 kind of player he reminds me of
Jonathan Allen but yes
Jonathan Ellen right so it's like
Jonathan Allen when I believe 15 but he
was hurt so it's like I mean he should
go ten well up to in top fifteen
pinzón need a little bit I I will say if
there's two guys in my top ten I'm
worried about its Higgins and Delpit and
I I think Higgins I don't know what the
hell all is going on with that passing
offense but he's just not look the same
this year also I get I get Josh
dachshund feel from him sometimes where
he's so good at the jump ball but then
you forget that he maybe doesn't do
anything else so yep but I think Mike
was have been a route runner so I'm a
little worried about that it would
Delpit it's like who are we getting
sucked in by character again um and I
think one thing is meat on us to find
out is is he holding back because he
knows he's going to the NFL because I
actually felt like I've seen it before
I really thought Durbin did that like I
remember watching them against
Louisville and I was like what are you
doing like why are you tackling and it
was so frustrating
it's think he was holding back to stay
healthy yeah I would agree with that one
but there are I mean a lot more games to
be played so this board is gonna shake
up don't freak out because me and Matt
have the same one player I'm looking at
and I'm like god I gotta move him up
Henry rugs I've met four I have I love
Henry rug hi I'm at 12th I mean it's
just hard to watch him play in this
speed is great but he I mean he's a
complete receiver too and he's not as
small as I thought he was either 6-foot
190 I I have him as my number two
receiver right now alright
he's like a healthy will follower to me
I think people forget almost sometimes
how good will fuller is a door Jason
hasn't my goodness I mean what else can
you really say I think that's a good
time to end the show
all right we're tops hopefully we see
you saturday morning in Dallas Texas
again nine o'clock off-the-cuff then we
will be back Monday morning our show
live from off the cuff and then the
regular schedule
Wednesday Connor I'll be back for mellow
and Connor will talk to y'all real soon